BEING WITH US NG.
THANK YOU.
>> MY SU. DODGE QUESTIONS AND R
FOUR C POLICE OFFICECAPITOL E TO
COMMITTEE MEETING LAST N
WITH DEMT BLND COMMENTS
COMPARING THE CAS TO
>> DID YOU WATCH THENYOF THE CA
6th?
OR NOT?
IT'SNOION.
IT ABSOLUTELY IRRELEVANT TO
MENDMENTIG
I WOULD LIKE TO STICK TO IT.
I'M Y , SIR M.
S THATU WADO,
MR. CHAIRMAN?
YDI HAVE THE FORT YOU.
VE US
DOWN THE ROAD OFD
MEE GHT IN THE ROOM.
GHT I WOULD CHECK ITITHEHE CAPI
WHO RIED THEIRES.
D HAVE EXPERIENCED,
MEDICAL IN.
OR NOTTOE FIRST OR FIFTH
AMENDMENT HE DOESN'T HAV
TESTIFY ABOUT IT. THE OURS,
STATENTTHAT TWES?LESURRECTION S
YOU TO STATEMENT.
ETATION OFY
TCV FOOTAGE E CAPITOL AND STATUA
SHOWED PEOPLE IN AFASHION STAYIS
YOU KNOW, IF YOU DT
TV FOOGE V
THINIT A NORMAL TOURIST.
ORDS.
>> I STAND BY THAT EXAT IT.
>> OKAY.
DO YOU AGREE OR DISAGREE WITCER
MEDIEVAL MOBHASEBALL S AND  ON,
THHEY WERE TERRORISTS?E TOURIST?
>> THAT STATEMENT DID NOT SAY
READ THE STATEMENT
CLARIFY FOR THE WHOLY
RIGHT NOW, F YOU TO WATCH IT.
GEH IT IN YOUR
.
OFFIHODGOFFA, RIMATIC BRAIN INA.
THINK THAT WHAT THEY
EXPERIENCED WAK BYTOURISTS OR T
VIOLENT INSURRECTIONS YOU VEOPP
THE WHOLE COUNTR F YOU  RFIRST
PART OF MYNT.
'RT INTEST
ST
CAN YO ME F
SECOND?
>> I HAVE READ YT
.
THE WHOLE COUNTRY D LOTS OPEOPL
TOURIST VISIT.
>> THAT IS NOT MY STATEMENT.
SAID -- AS YOU QUOTED AND
THENUST MISQUOTED.FY RIGHTERUST
POLOF
BAE MEMBND
NAAND THEY TOOK  WITH --TENTBEC.
E TAKING ISSUE WIT
INTERNETE  PEOPL WERE RI
AND THEYTS.ER
W EA>>EL I'M NOT RNST MEME.
HERE TO DISCU THIS
>> OKAY.T, MR.
Y ANSWER THE
I APPRECIATE THAT.
TO ANSWER ITF
I SAID WHAT YOU IDE HERE TO DIS
AMENDMENT ANBVREED
HER
THIS IS NOT.
YOU VOTED NO ON GIVING TIME, MR.
CO MEDALS TO THE DEFENDED LIVES
OZENS  WHOM WEREOU
HO, PEOPLEOST
EXTENDING CONGRESSIOGOLD TRAUMA
MEDALS TO THEM.
WHY DID
>> AGAIN, THAT HAS NOTHING TDO
TH
I BACK  THER. CLYDE.
>> THAT I ENDMENT -- EXCE A GOL
THEY'VE DONE.
BY
RE
I'SOT  THAT ORIDGE INFORMATION.
>> I'LL RECLAIM MY TIME.'M NOT
BECAUSE SHE IS THENE WHO -- E M
CONGRESSIONAL GOED THE
ICE AND THOSE
WHO PROTECTED THE UNITEDTA
CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6th.
I'M NG Y O
TO TELL US WHY YERE ON MEMBERS N
IT.
>> I JUST YOU LISTEN.
>> YOU TOLD MENO YO WHICH WAS O?
>> TARLA
H S APPROPRIATE.ITASLLPROPRIATE
T CAPITOLPOLICE FOR ALL OF
THEY HAVE DEFENDED THIS
E  1, 1990CIE I THIN- OL
AT DIED FROM T WOUNDSAC
DID YOU KNOW>> SO YOU'RE
UGH?
IS THAT UROINT?
T TO TO.TO THESE PEOPLE BUT YON
THAT, MR.HAD JUST, HE
OFFICERS WEFD OUR VE
ON JRYth
E LEVE
THIS ROOM ABOUT DEFUNDING TH, AT
WE HEARD THIS MORNING.T ACCEPT I
I FIND THETORIC
DANGEROUS, DESCRIBING HI
K PLACAYS
ANALOGOU TOURISM.
AND I WOULEAGUE TO
AN TO
THOSCE